good evening members welcome to this
evening's joint transportation board the
14th of december
2021. there's no members of the public
here
we have a few extra people here that are
welcome as well and you'll meet them as
time goes on okay the first item on the
uh the fire procedure first is the fire
if the fire alarm is activated please
forget the offices via the stairs
opposite the lifts in this foyer please
do not use a lift assemble in holy
square on the green and officers will
assist you and advise when it is deemed
safe to refer return to the chamber
could everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are switched
silent and they are not used to make or
receive calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
i would advise that the filming takes
place anyone in attendance
in the public areas may have that image
captured i urge anyone filming
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children present does anyone intend to
film in the meeting
okay i'll skip the next part
does any member wish to speak under 20.1
okay
all right apologies for absence and
gender item one we have cornford who is
actually a new member
um france hart game and yates and lewis
cornford is a
council called westgate town councillor
which is center apologies this evening
we have a council quitters and is also a
member new member of minster paris world
council but he isn't here at the moment
so
right
are are there any other apologies
it seems
no okay
no thank you
agenda item two declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
no okay thank you
minutes of agenda item three or minutes
of the previous meeting do members agree
that the minutes of the joint
transportation board meeting held on
16th of september 2021 be approved and
signed as a correct record
thank you can i have a proposal please
thank you
i'm going to have a second to please
do all members agree
thank you
my agenda item 4 is a highways works
program 2021 22 and 2022-23
i hope that you've all looked at your
your your
agenda items and gone through them
because we do not have no presentation
from paul this evening unfortunately
so can i ask do any members have any
questions or comments on the report if
you do
james will take down your your questions
and they will be sent to whichever
officer they are relevant so do members
have any questions please on the gender
item 4 highway works programme
no members
no
right
so this report is for information
please members note the report
thank you
agenda item 6 is a local winter service
plan
once again do members have any questions
or comments on the report
no comments
no no thank you
the report is for information please can
members note the report
active agenda item six is the active
travel plan 828 canterbury road i called
upon parish council blankly was asked to
speak on behalf of burgenton paris
parish council
thank you
thank you chairman um came to me rather
quickly
um
thank you i've been asked by the parish
council to come along to express um
uh our viewers about the uh
the plan for the active travel route um
i think it's fair to say
first off that the parish council
recognizes the benefits of
cycling how it can benefit physical and
mental health
and how it can also contribute to
improvements in the environment where
it can it allows
uh people to take short journeys uh or
by bicycle rather than by motor car or
by some other means that's potentially
damaging or causing congestion
however we feel that the proposals for
this particular cycle route um are are
not well thought through
and uh potentially um offer a risk to
health and and the environment
um there's three grounds really on on
which we we take this view the first is
around uh the the evidence base
um we've we've not seen uh any evidence
to underpin
the rationale for for this this
particular route
uh if it's uh to substitute short cut
short car journeys um for for cycling um
then you know we would the evidence
presumably is there
um we know that um the ursuline school
and key ether bots are both
major
destinations
for young people who potentially could
cycle
but we don't know how many of those walk
how many come by public transport how
many are potential cyclists and
therefore potential users of the
psychopath itself so the absence of any
evidence
to us suggests that that this perhaps
isn't an evidence-based uh initiative
the second and and um equally important
is is around the impact of the the the
proposed changes
uh just just to remind you the um the
outcome of the proposal would be that
the current
two-lane dual carriageway
would become um a two-lane uh single
carriageway
uh route and instead of being a forty
mile an hour limit would be thirty
now it has been said that in some parts
of the
the the the uh the route uh it does
become a single lane where there's cars
parked along by ursuline and kittel but
for um quite quite frequently but
largely it is a dual carriageway with
with two carriageways
the impact of that
on
general traffic flows would you know we
don't understand what that might be
because we don't believe the analysis
has been done
but more importantly there are 2 000
houses proposed to be built in westgate
and 1600 in birchington
and
up to now the planning for those
developments
and the associated relief road the inner
circuit
has been based on
the idea that uh the route between
birchington and margaret would be as it
is now
so the impact of the potential of the
proposed changes
on
those assumptions that underlie those
developments
uh are not understood
and we believe they probably haven't
even been looked at
so there are some big issues there
when we come to the um
the design of the uh the route itself we
believe that it um
it risks putting cyclists and
pedestrians in conflict in in certain
areas and it also
because it doesn't physically segregate
them on on footpaths and also because if
it were children who are using their
bicycles more to go to school
they've still got to cross the dual
carriageway and it potentially puts them
in conflict with with the traffic as
well
the
guidance that uh was issued in 2020 by
the government around um cycle routes uh
it is only guidance it's not mandatory
but um in the forward to that the
minister at the time did say that um too
much cycling infrastructure is
substandard providing little protection
from motorized traffic and giving up the
very places it is most needed
some is actually worse than nothing
because it entices novice cyclists with
the promise of protection then abandons
them at the most important place
poor cycling infrastructure discourages
cycling and waste public money
i think
our understanding of this proposal at
the moment suggests that that
paragraph would perhaps capture the the
the views of virtue parish council as it
stands
thank you
thank you very much indeed do any of us
have any questions
thanks sherman um it's not a question as
such but um
uh i called i asked for this to be put
on the agenda because
i know there's been a consultation
um
and
i suspect that most of the county
certainly the county councillors
put their comments on that consultation
but i thought it was
i thought it was imperative that the
joint transportation board had a view
whether it was for or against um
i thought it should certainly come from
members to to discuss
um i suspect that the view is um
fairly mutual for many from what i've
seen and certainly from people i've
spoken to
um
but i thank councillor blankly for for
his comments i think he's being generous
money is offer money is offered for
active travel
and it has long been the tradition
that if there's money to be had you grab
it even if
what you do with it isn't quite certain
or not even possibly a good idea
if people want to cycle
albeit not directly to the schools but
there is a perfectly adequate active
travel plan and it's called the
esplanade that goes all the way along
from birchington to westbrook
so
and it's only a few yards north
of the one that they're planning now
i travel
the dual carriageway quite a bit
it already takes me 20 minutes to get
from broadstairs out of planet
uh because usually it's when
it's peak times
and it's single lane
and it's so nice coming back because
it's not single lane then because i
usually come back when it's out of peak
hours
but this is the major road into margate
and broad stairs
and i think that to start suggesting
that it should be narrowed with an
active travel well with the cycle path
whilst
i applaud the attempt to make people
cycle more
i think that this is
money wasted
my opinion is that uh it's not going to
resolve any issues i think that you will
have a continuous single lane there
whereas at the moment it's only at peak
times
um and then for the rest of the day it's
pretty good
so i think personally that this is
a waste of that money
i think it's a waste of government money
on a project that
fails on many in many ways and i would
suggest that um it's flavor of the month
my recommendation is that we
do not recommend this
as a
as a
plan that should be put in place but
that is my opinion thank you
thank you councillor binks um next one
is his council fellows please yeah thank
you um i'm a bit disappointed there's no
one from kcc here this evening because i
think that's a color questions i'd like
to ask them something i'd like to say
because uh
you know i don't know where they're
coming up with these hair brain ideas to
be honest i mean we've had we had two
failed projects in in danny already in
westgate and indeed in in your in your
broadstairs so
my biggest concern is the ward council
of birchen is the closure of epple road
i think we've already got a closure of
um traffic coming out of dom neva onto
canterbury road so anybody living on
that side of the road who wants to come
out to get towards london is going to
head right through our village at
bircherton it's already
speed restricted anyway 20 mile now and
humps and whatever it is it's absolutely
ridiculous and i think there's no way
that we can support it um not in a
million years that's that's all i want
to say i think
nick i think thank you for your analysis
i think you know you've done some good
work on i've
purchased a parish council so uh yeah i
won't be supporting it i can't support
it i think we should you know strongly
put uh some sort of
uh
campaign against it personally i don't
know who kcc came up with the idea i
don't know
thank you councilman councillor wright
is my next on my list please
thank you chair um i actually live on
the canterbury road
i've actually since since we had a
briefing um and it's
it's quite well documented that my
thoughts were unnecessary ill-conceived
and dangerous
there's not one word about hgvs at
peak times during the day we have hgvs
coaches and four bus routes
now
when
and there's no mention of the emergency
services
and
two weeks ago i was walking to the post
box and a fire engine came along the
cars actually come up onto the pavement
so
my fear is that if there's a cycle lane
there what do you do do you hit the
cyclist i do you crash into the
emergency vehicle
i've also i did ask the
person that thought this
scheme up
had they actually monitored the bicycles
that actually used the canterbury road
i've been doing that
and on average i see four
in the morning
most of the children walk to school
and i think actually
children walking to school is far more
bet is far healthier for them for their
mental health as well because when you
walk to school with your friends you
make friends and
you
do your homework if you haven't done it
there's all sorts of social integration
with those children which i think
especially this generation now they've
been deprived of in the last couple of
years
when you're on a bike
you don't talk to anybody
which isolates you and it has there are
young gentlemen who think it's good to
have five people on a bike so what
happens if an ambulance comes along and
you have to get out of the way that it's
a really bad accident waiting to happen
i won't be supporting this
recommendation
thank you council crow brown
thank you uh yes i echo the sentiments
of
all the comments made by councillors uh
i was asked by the kcc leader roger
gough uh well i've
what my opinion was and uh as a former
racing cyclist i used to do about 10 000
miles a year
i said that is not the right route to
come in to go into margae it should have
been along the coast as best as possible
there should have also been engagement
with birchington and westgate
councils before it went out to the
public
yeah
as has been said apple road being shut
off
councillor cornford contacted me today
um
what about people are lighting from the
buses
there's going to be conflict with the
cycles crossing
that route so yeah i won't support it
thank you
comments and questions will be sent to
wendy barman who is the schemes program
program manager of east at kcc
so your comments will go obviously to
this particular person who hopefully
oh thank your pardon
can i just ask
if it's possible with your permission
that uh we actually
um
make a recommendation that we do not
support this plan
i think we should do more than just
comment to an officer but actually say
it is my opinion if members are agreed
okay it was information but i think i'll
agree to that i think that that needs to
be done so yes it will be we are staged
it says in the terms of reference we are
supposed to make revenue recommendations
would you like to ask the case this
encounters if they know if there's going
to be more scrutiny i know there's a
consultation where we all know
consultation's
fairly ignored anyway but is there going
to be some scrutiny of this or what's
the next
stage on this
well councillor goff said it if there
was a lot of negatives in this
consultation
it will be pulled this project and the
money will go back to central government
that's what he told me
what gets me is we we're the we're the
kent county
members and all these plans and
decisions go over our heads
we sit here and listen to all the local
concerns
and
i've always said that kcc
it's like an ivory tower they don't
understand it's just a rubber stamping
it's dreadful but
i'm going to go to cat sphinx face
um
yeah in relation to that i would say
that uh at scrutiny
we are looking and we've raised it at
planning because uh at planning the
planning committee in kcc is
only noted it has to uh is only allowed
to note
the letters that have already been sent
and one of them was for birchington
neighborhood plan
which
i disagreed with the comments
and asked
whose comments are they kcc or an
officer
and with what authority does that
officer then
come with those comments because they've
not been passed by anybody else
and in fact at scrutiny we will be
looking into the
comments the letters that are sent
to
district councils
regarding planning applications big
planning applications
which do not always seem to reflect
members opinions
the counselors opinions but in fact
reflect an officer's opinion
and
we are a member-led counsel not an
officer-led counsel
officers carry out the
the policies but the policies are made
by
the members
and it is a point that's being taken up
and i'd like to speak to councillor
blackley afterwards about it regarding
birshington but um i think you know it
is in this case
i'm very reluctant and i would
appreciate the chairs
agreeing that we recommend that we do
not
uh we do not support this
do you wish to speak council rights
only in as much uh catches chunk that uh
both barry lewis and myself were given
a briefing from from
david brazier
um he didn't like what we said but
anyway we did have an opportunity
okay i think all the ingredients that we
recommend her recommendation is that we
we don't understand
seven
which is the future high streets funds
ramsgate highways improvement scheme i
call upon mr burton asset development
manager of tdc to introduce the report
mr burton
thank you chair
um hopefully everyone's had a chance to
read the um the attached uh documents
that went out of your your
agenda um
i'm just to outline a few key points and
obviously um it is here for you to
to take view of the consultation that's
recently taken place um and
to comment on that
as you as you may wish and for us then
to review those comments and progress to
the next stages of the project and then
hopefully subsequently deliver the
scheme on the ground so
as it was introduced the funding has
come from the future high street fund
we've got a new region of 1.6 million to
deliver a highway improvement scheme
in essence that's to enable more
connectivity between the harbour and the
town side to the south and the north
side of
harbour parade
and that's to
enable the the higher densities of
people within the harbour area to try
and migrate them into the town and ease
crossing and
the environment of that that seafront
road
so in terms of the consultation that has
taken place
um this the scheme was originally uh
concepted with uh landscape coastal
community team and ranching town council
the
use of kcc was involved initially on the
scheme
before we then appointed
highway engineers to develop skin a
little bit more for the consultation
the work is under a 278 agreement
section 278
because it hasn't gone through any
planning process and doesn't need to the
idea is that we
take it to the to the public to to get
that consultation feedback and that
consultation running from the 12th of
12th of uh october through to the 26th
of november and within that period
we had 182 responses which is really
really pleasing to be honest with you uh
the number of uh participants who
responded on that and we had two drop-in
sessions at the customs house in
ramsgate one in the afternoon and one in
the evening
of which we we
we had 46 uh attendees or thereabouts uh
come have a look at the scheme as it was
delivered uh or proposed and
in that
consultation session we had members from
kcc highways there
and our highway engineers there to to
comment uh on the schemes and answer
questions as we could
so
on this um
i'd like to as you as you see if you've
looked at the agenda
in essence there's a positive view about
the scheme in the public 82 percent
agree or strongly agree about the scheme
um
75
think the objectives of the scheme will
be met in
in delivering this
um
the key points
in our
submission here we have included all the
comments that were made
through the consultation online
as obviously as well as
through the visits and there's quite a
number of pages of them as you've you've
probably seen and gone through
i think the key the key elements or key
messages it's always a little bit
subjective on on comments and trying to
to put them into some key points but i
think what we've we've generally picked
up from the comments is that
um there's a lot of comments or there's
a lot of you in terms of
pedestrianization
of harbour parade from marine marina
walk over to the pavilion sands
the weather spoons
also there's a lot of comments in terms
of the parking restrictions along that
road um i'd like to say at that point
though both both those elements are
outside of our scope of work we've got
quite a tight scope of what we're
allowed to do for the funding uh and but
they're outside of that but the comments
are still you know extremely important
to us and i'll move
further on that in a moment
one of the other key um
areas of concern or comment were
positive mostly positive actually and a
few in
worried
comments in regards to the 20 mile an
hour zone so most people like that
extend it out further than where we've
currently currently proposed so we we
have extended the scheme into the town
um from what was initially looked at
prior prior to the consultation
to to try and help there but in that the
main concern is the madeira walk and
that we extend the 20 mile an hour
up in towards wellington crescent um to
slow traffic as it comes down the hill
and
you know very very point um also
potentially a number of assets would
just be extended generally within the
ramsgate area and then down
um
and possibly up towards addington street
although that's a little bit more more
difficult in that respect
there have been concerns just general
concerns about the the state of the high
street area as such because this doesn't
affect that as you know directly but
there were comments on that and there
were some comments uh in in relation to
the north bus lay by that's been
slightly reduced because at the moment
um some of the buses do cause some
congestion by sticking out and we're
just reducing that slightly to have um i
think
a slightly
less area
for the bus but we have to maintain or
try and maintain the current regulations
on what we're allowed to do in terms of
distances from traffic lights etc but on
the offset of that um quite a few people
have also indicated that why why isn't
leopold street used more often
rather than
waiting necessarily at the the
on the harbour itself you know
and that's a point that we can take back
to stagecoach as part of this
comments uh and consultation
um
you'll see that some key stakeholders
ramsgate town council um you know
generally positive with the proposal
would like some monitoring on it as well
which is which is fine and which we have
to do as part of the funding so uh
that's fantastic
the police in essence are again positive
that the comment is a you know
under the general um national policy
stance on 20 mile an hour those that
they they don't police that 20 mile an
hour zone they don't anywhere but um in
essence um
they see the the use of the raised table
should induce a reduced speed in there
as well which we're trying to achieve
just going back on the comments and what
i've picked up
quite a few of them are outside of our
scope of what we can do
but having said that this is only one
funding stream within roundscape that's
coming up and i think you know the use
of this consultation that's as has
highlighted other areas of the town that
can you know would benefit from the you
know these general comments as as well
as site-pacific comments
and in particular um harbour parade
where you've got the double parking
outside the the cafes and
shops there and also the narrow pathway
that you have a pedestrian pathway along
that side as well um so you know these
these are good comments not necessary
that we can pick up in this scheme but
need to need to be taken forward on on
the future highest uh not if you try to
be leveling up
funding that's available together with
some comments about general signage as
well maybe you know reducing clutter a
bit more directional size to help people
find the car parks etc within within the
town more easily
our next steps will be to
look at the consultation as as i've said
look at the comments in relation to
those key points go back with our design
team in fact we'll meet in later this
week with the design team to try and
incorporate these you know in particular
extended 20 mile an hour limit
um
what we can do there
have a a think on maybe some of the
crossing points because there was a
comment on madeira walk there's a little
bit up the road
and try and bring that down so try and
pick these up so um it was a positive
experience for us uh i think you know
what has come out of it has been some
really positive um
questions and solutions or engagement
that we look to take forward
the other thing we'd like to do is
probably do another release press
release or
maybe directly to certain stakeholders
saying what we've taken on board in
terms of the consultation to give some
feedback because you know you know as
you may know lots of people may think
the consultation is you know it's just a
tick box exercise but it it actually
isn't in in this instance at all and
shouldn't be in any instance um so we
will take on board these comments and
sort of develop them out really
so
it's been brought to
to your board to to
really just advise and and hope we have
you know we're able to progress that
forward onto the next stages um this
scheme is it's a 278 scheme um section
278 will will have the detailed design
developed out more it will then go to uh
you probably all know a stage two uh
safety audit to ensure that um what's
what's being proposed in the detail is
acceptable to kcc and to the highways
and then it will go out for
um
commencement on site looking at autumn
next year so we want to commence and do
the works within outside the the peak
obviously um season uh for the tourist
trade so it'll be through autumn through
to spring
um i think that concludes unless
piano has any comments that you need to
bring
thank you thank you chair
thank you very much into you thank you
right do members have any questions or
comments
i'll respond to that because i i do live
in ramsgate now our concerns there
obviously he's going to be a bit of a
balance what people want in ramsgate
i've lived all my life
when you turn right what was the old
natwest bank is italian restaurant today
you you need a cold dissect sign there
because everybody's going down to the
pavilion with weather spoons to go
nowhere
we used to have a highway that belongs
to kcc in front of those new flats
why can't that road be open so let the
traffic flow because when you go down to
the what was the old marina is it's dead
end
if we open that road up which belong to
us anyway
not to the people that own the flats
that's our seafront
so when you turn right what is now a
what was nat west and then the pizza
place and now it's italian restaurant
which is great news for homeschooling
all the traffic comes down there and
you've got a pinch point as you quite
like you said but the two coaches park
and if they park around a corner
so that is a concern if we could open
that road up
which i've been even casey years ago
and sometimes i think i'm just talking
to a brick wall because we do live in
ramsey it's it's a wonderful it's a
wonderful seafood
but you can't get nowhere so you've got
all that traffic going down there to go
where nowhere just round that round
about and back up again it really rubbed
our noses
there's some good things on the town
center campaigner
uh for all these fanuc towns because
they have suffered with westwood cross
but they're suffering as well now so i'm
really interested how things are
leveling up is it's great news
and i will talk about ramsgate ramsey is
a market town we need our market back on
a friday end of
to bring life back into that town
you need clean the streets
you need policemen on the beat the
amount of stuff that's walking out them
shops daily just by a theft and say they
can't keep taking it on
but i'm i'm more than interested if i
can help you anyway
thank you
thank you very much councilman
i'll try not to to repeat what uh
counselor shocker said there's another
old ramsgate family
um yeah
i did have a few questions actually um
one is
what is the aim of this because if the
aim is to connect with the town
um we haven't we have plenty of visitors
i say we but ramsgate has plenty of
visitors
going to the harbour
they might venture up harbour street as
well
but they take one look at what used to
be called the marketplace
uh where the all the four roads meet
and they don't go any further and who
can blame them it's shabby it's half
empty
it doesn't look very appealing and
that's your major problem the high
street king street queen street and
harbour street were able to have
to be full of shops and they're not
anymore
it has to be
brought in but it has to be brought in
not sort of higgledy-piggledy but
actually it has to be a plan
not
wait till everybody goes bankrupt in a
shop and then it's left forever about 10
years until somebody takes it and builds
a flat
that builds flats there or something it
has to be a planned
reduction of the town center
to survive
because i do think actually local shops
will come back the demise i think of the
the large shops is something will take
years to um
to to resolve and maybe change back
again
but
i still think that no matter which way
you look at it
ramsgate has
a big town centre which is too big for
today's market
and that's got to be
made smaller
but in a much more obvious way so i
think that's the problem you've got is
when you're attracting people up to up
through harbour street what are you
attracting them to
and if it's just to walk vaguely up a
few half empty shop well streets with
half empty shops
then
they're not going to go very far
so yes i agree with you and i also agree
with you on the access
um i've never understood the the the
rationale for for
a allowing parking in front of all the
little cafes that are opposite the
harbour
anyone else would say you must be mad i
suggested it to to town council
um years ago why didn't just get rid of
it
you don't park if you want to sit on on
a pavement
anywhere in the world you wouldn't dream
of sitting on the pavement and looking
at the side of a car
or two cars in ramsey because he's often
double parked you wouldn't dream of it
you sit there to look at the harbour
not to look at a car so that would be
the first thing i'd get rid of i'm sorry
it might upset a couple of people but
you know there is a car park opposite so
um
and you know but i'd get rid of it
because it's only a few parking spaces
um anyway
and the second thing is
instead of putting in that well they put
that roundabout in but i never
understood why they closed off that road
because
the one thing you do if you're in a car
and you're looking at a place for the
first time is you drive along the
seafront
and you have a look and then you decide
where you're going to stop
and if there's a nice large car park at
one end
fine you know but that's where you drive
and so i think the first thing they
should do is make that open again i
never understood why it was closed off
um to me it seemed pointless
and the other thing is with military
road
same thing as harbour parade
cars driving along the harbour wall
really
you know
they don't other places
they might do out of the main hours
but they don't do it all the time
but we've got cars motorbikes all sorts
of things driving up there
again if you if you want to encourage
restaurants and cafes
and they're all sitting right by the
harbour
they do not want to see vehicles going
past there are a lot of good comments
from a lot of people in
a lot of good comments
um and they all seem to make this that
you know forget the ones that say oh
wouldn't it be lovely to have 20 20 mile
per hour who's going to enforce it we've
had 20 mile per hour in in broad stairs
for years in the high street
and
councillors both council and councillor
dave sorens know that on a saturday
night you'll see somebody screaming down
there at 60 and who's going to stop them
it happens all the time so
20 miles per hour is a nice thing to
have if you've got cameras up
which is what they do in london
it's enforced there are cameras every 20
30 yards
and i would complain and i have already
complained campaigned in in kcc
that the they use more cameras and make
them cheaper
so that you know it's not astronomical
to put them in but cameras you could
have there
um the military road
as i said i think that you should be
looking at somehow
accessing it for the large vehicle
certainly
accessing it via the tunnel
and accessing along the road
the other way
you can also park along west cliff
on the um what used to be called the
artificial beach and
but you can you can you know there's
plenty of parking along there
and that doesn't interfere with anyone
it doesn't interfere with the beaches or
anything and it's not too far to walk
and he's on the flat
which is the great advantage that
ramsgate has over broadstairs it's on
the flat
so
you know i think if you're going to look
at the
vehicles
you've got to look at managing them
and i'm not sure that sir leopold sweeps
big enough to put that many in either
and plus it's it's a pretty tatty
looking place it smells
you take the lifts at your peril
if they work
and half the time nothing else works
anyway so you're not paying
so you know sorry
there are plenty of things to spend your
money on and i'm a bit worried that um
we're missing the main thing which is
you've got to look at the
before you talk about bringing people up
into the town you've got to have a town
that's worth coming to
and i'm by no means saying it isn't
ramsgate's a good town and that's where
a lot of money should have be gone in
the last 20 years not in margate but in
ramsgate because ramsgate has one big
asset
and that's the harbour
thank you council vince i think council
shanks would like to speak again
i try to make this brief i quite agree
with what canada brings does because she
probably understands ramsey just as much
as i one thing that we
we got the best harbour there is
it's a war harbour
and when i was on kcc before i'm sure
things that just fall on death is every
time that tunnel is closed it's during
the daytime now we've asked for that
tunnel to be repaired at night time
so those lorries don't have to go past
all those cafes
and because it is a working harbor it's
struggling i know but you've got brett's
and those lorries go along there and the
people trying to serve drinks
but they still manage but wouldn't it be
great to any work must be done at night
time on that tunnel so at least it's
open so all those heavy i mean god knows
how much that tunnel 80 million pound
underneath them allotments when we had a
ferry let's let's try and make use and
try and make things pleasant for people
that are trying to survive
and get back to that road along that
ramsay seafront
be wonderful because you've got a
thousand people a week going to those
tunnels walton tunnels and if they could
come down there and there's nowhere to
park outside where the spoons or the
turquoise they probably go along as well
we'll park up there and we'll use some
of the facilities that are not used
because it's it's a dead end street
and they could go all along that
seafront
turn left where the closed toilets have
been closed about 30 years and go back
up the hill and park up along the top
and go the same clue
the potential in rams is fantastic which
is never used
thank you any other members would like
to make comments or questions
right can i just comment just just
briefly
comment on a couple of those points um i
don't understand where you're both
coming from in terms of the the tunnel
and military road
um i say the the harbour parade tours
where the spoons that was the one of the
key you obviously read the comments that
was one of the key areas where
everyone's saying about pedestrian eyes
and then and lose the the on-street
parking
i i can't comment about the in front of
the new development to be true for i
don't know about the land ownership and
what the what what the elements that are
there that's not outside mine but i will
take these forward um these comments
forward to to the appropriate people um
as you've mentioned you know including
the port in rel in regards to the tunnel
element as well um
no problems there at all to be honest
with you um
there is a there is a a high street
um future high street fund for the the
other half of the funding shall we say
so this is the highway fund there is
some elements for the town itself to try
and uh engage with the empty shops and
to
bring that side of the the town back
into into use so i do understand where
you're coming from um that's at the
moment i think there's some hard there's
harvest hob street itself has got some
activity but the whole fund extends up
towards where the old argus was or the
natwest bank um in the high street so
hopefully you know it's it's similar to
a thi scheme um and so hopefully you
know land owner landlords or or owner
occupiers will you know take that
opportunity to to try and get some
improvement on their property as well uh
and that's and so there's two there's
two schemes in fact there's the the
future high street fund this one the
other side of this
um about workspace et cetera and try and
get used to in properties but there's
also that the high street has which is
about improving the frontages as well so
it's more of a material a built
environment scheme which is like the thi
and that improves the frontage which
again hopefully encourages people to to
spend more money on the property and and
to maybe open up some of these
properties that you know have been
closed
um i say that's just wanted to sort of
uh reiterate that on those and again
that the leveling up fund has got
opportunities in other sites within the
harbour um i believe one of them's piers
up peer yard and so it's all there's a
bit of connectivity there to you know
when that scheme looks is being looked
at to see what can be done to pick up
these points that have been raised and
as as i said before i think it's a you
know the consultation is primarily for
this scheme that i'm delivering this
area but it's actually opened up and
commented quite quite nicely on a number
of peripheral areas that are really
important to round to gate so yeah
just thank you for your time there
thank you very much
um with the recommendations of the are
to use the information for their
consultation
right for the project to progress can we
recommend the project progresses with
and endorse the changes what members
have brought up this evening obviously
grant has said that he will look into
his comments so can we make them a
recommendation we will progress a pr
product but with
endorse these changes
is that fair yes we agree can i have a
proposal please
thank you and a segment please thank you
okay
i think
[Applause]
all right that's if members all agree
thank you
thank you well that concludes the
business for this evening thank you for
your attendance i'd like to wish you all
a very very happy and healthy christmas
and new year
thank you for attending and
thank you bye
you